welcome back to las vegas now this is a
great time to discuss immunization
awareness i spoke with a doctor from
southwest medical associates the
sponsors of this next segment to answer
some frequently asked questions about
vaccines
we have to talk vaccinations that is
definitely a topic on everybody's mind
right now um so let's
quickly ask questions um first and
foremost some people want to know aren't
vaccinations just for kids why why do
adults need to be vaccinated
you know it's a very good question i
mean we see adults a lot of adults in
our practice we get that question all
the time but the answer is no it's not
just for kids certainly kids need to
have their you know vaccinations based
on their age recommendation but
adults definitely need vaccinations i
mean every year thousands hundreds of
thousands of adults get sick because
they were not vaccinated for
illnesses
okay and if someone is in good health a
lot of times they're wondering why
should i get vaccinated
sure
i mean a way to look at it is as
prevention right prevention is the best
cure so we want to prevent illnesses
before they happen so
we have
vaccines for several illnesses that used
to be rampant you know years ago and
they would kill
kids and adults now we have vaccines for
them so look at it more as a prevention
and so that you can continue to maintain
your good health what are some of the
more vaccine preventable diseases
um well for now um you know
for chickenpox so common before people
used to just get in a room without
somebody else that had chickenpox now
you can get a vaccine
the flu certainly you know every year
that is offered um hepatitis a hepatitis
b
hpv you know for kids to prevent it's
actually to prevent cancer cerebral
cancer
measles moms rubella all those illnesses
that you know these are all preventable
by getting the vaccine are vaccines
actually safe
so that's also you know a very good and
a very valid question i mean vaccines
are tested and monitored i mean they go
through a rigorous process before the
fda you know uh gives approval for them
to be used um now you know this year the
covet vaccine everything happened so
quickly but you know millions of people
throughout the world have received it
and they have deemed to be safe
now let's talk about the covet 19
vaccine in particular let's break that
down for people so they can really
understand
what's being offered here so you know
the question uh we get is
you know why should i get the coveted
vaccine
um one one important reason is to you
know lower the risk for getting cobit
19. now even if a person were to get a
breakthrough infection after the
vaccination their risk for severe
illness and or hospitalization is
reduced
it overall helps to protect you know
others that are immune compromised and
may not be able to get the vaccine
and for others in our community
especially our younger children that are
not yet eligible for the vaccine and
this segment is all about immunization
awareness so where can people get more
information certainly cdc.gov
the southern nevada health district.org
those are the two big ones that i would
recommend
thank you dr carr and southwest medical
for sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada just
call
702-877-5199 or visit
smalv.com for more information